in the early 20s a recession swept
across the country
resulting in the closure of many plants
and factories
thousands were left jobless people
relocated to larger cities
in hopes that more opportunities could
be found but the unemployment numbers
far exceeded the positions that were
available
poorer communities with cheaper housing
began to swell and gangs offered these
people a way to survive
and feed their families with the
downfall of government infrastructure
these groups only further expanded
claiming whole neighborhoods and zones
as their territory
with little resistance from the
government and bigger corporations
in this video we'll be covering some of
the gangs that can be found in night
city
in cyberpunk 2077
[Music]
[Music]
the sixth street gang was founded by
veterans of the fourth corporate war
tired of the night city police
department being incapable of
maintaining order
they joined together to keep the peace
they ultimately decided that it was time
to take matters into their own hands
utilizing the rigorous training they had
undergone in the years spent well
enlisted
as well as having their connections to
military-grade weapons and equipment
they came together to keep the local
gangs under control
a force to protect the people who were
unable to protect themselves
their motto was to bring justice to the
city
but unfortunately this was lost over
time today
they are no better than a traditional
gang abusing their power over local
communities
they are known to pressure local
businesses into paying tribute and
protection money
along with a number of other criminal
activities
these days the members of sixth street
are veterans of more recent battles
retired military personnel and discharge
corporate security officers who are
unable to find other employment
the rest are civilians who underwent
military training after joining the
group
their motivation of bringing justice to
the city is still the same
but their interpretation of what is
acceptable to gain such a thing has
become misguided over time
the sixth street gang takes part in
extortion gun smuggling
and robberies and they also have a deep
connection to the nomad groups
outside of night city another source of
income for the gang
comes from the stealing and modifying of
vehicles they have a number of techies
and can be seen in garages and workshops
all around the city
6th street also offers a combat taxi for
hire service
which is popular among edgerunners and
mercenaries
although they are a criminal gang sixth
street is generally ignored by the
police force
provided that they stick to their turf
as the group does already expect some
sort of order in their neighborhoods
corporations particularly ones with
focus on military supplies
will often turn a blind eye towards them
as they are essentially another paying
customer
the animals are an aggressive street
fighting gang who place emphasis on
physical power above everything else
traditional electronic cyberware is of
no interest to them as they prefer
custom body enhancements and
modifications
driven by their fascination with the
feral primordial side of human nature
they see the gap between man and animal
and have made it their goal to bridge
this gap
in an attempt to establish themselves as
the new dominant species
to achieve this they are heavy substance
uses including testosterone and animal
supplements
including equine growth hormone to help
feed the ever growing quest
to become larger and stronger
they are experienced fighters and are
trained in various martial arts
they love to brawl and enjoy engaging in
anything that shows off their brute
physical force
constantly trying to test their strength
and skill they will often take on
extremely dangerous cyber enhanced
opponents
whether their foes are members of other
gangs the police or corporate forces
is of no concern to them it is almost an
unwritten expectation for them to
challenge themselves like this
in order to sharpen their effectiveness
in combat
internally the relationship between each
member is just as animalistic
they are divided into small packs led by
the biggest and strongest alpha member
in any disputes is settled by combat
finishing only when one individual
is fully submitted to the other
with no set or permanent location the
animals roam the suburbs like a menacing
pack
ready to take on anything and anyone
but be warned it isn't unusual to see a
large number of packs coming together in
one location
and this usually means something big is
about to go down and the area should be
avoided at all costs
other than their sheer size they can
also be identified by their tattoos
along with the artificial animalistic
features these range from purely
cosmetic modifications
like spotted or striped skin to the more
extreme remodeling
like be stool jaws and implanted muscles
this savagery and durability make them
highly sought after bouncers and
bodyguards
and for this reason they often found
spread throughout night city
they've also cornered the illegal
substance trade where they manufacture
and sell drugs
in particular anabolic steroids
the animals are well known for their
violent raids on residential districts
and other gangs home turf certain packs
specialise in different operations
including reading drug stores targeting
chemical transportation
robbing pharmaceutical companies and
ransacking drug dealers
all of which goes back to their own
substance production activities
one of the largest gangs in night city
are the tiger claws
predominantly asian they are territorial
resourceful
and ruthless their primary objective
is to dominate and control the streets
of japan town where they are based
they also take immense satisfaction in
the occasional forcible acquisition of
other gang's businesses
and they tend to do this through any
means necessary
their methodology in regards to business
is incredibly similar to gangs such as
the accuser
an altercation with even the lowest
member can result in a quick and violent
reaction by the rest of the game
the leaders of the tiger clause believe
that in the long run business is
preferable
to constant bloodshed and battle however
they also realize that you can only get
so much done
without a machine gun and sadistic
brutes to further their cause
and this is where the low-level soldiers
come in highly aggressive
violent and sadistic they are prone to
undermining the superiors ideology of
the organization
but it doesn't matter as long as the top
brass get what they want in the end
by means of torture abduction provoking
fights
and sexual assault amongst others it
seems the ramifications
are near non-existent however
any act of retaliation on these
individuals will bring the whole gang's
wrath
upon the perpetrators in question the
gang must always appear united
and victorious in battle regardless of
what's going on behind the scenes
it is almost always advisable to avoid
retaliation and direct encounters with
any members of the tigers
unless there exists significant
connections with higher ranking members
the tiger claws are easily recognised by
the asian luminous tattoos
fast street bikes and katanas
night city's lead after dark
entertainment district is japan town
and this is where the tigers control a
large portion of the businesses
brothels bars casinos restaurants
and even the brain dance clubs are
mostly run by the tigers
[Music]
mostly legal businesses they also
provide a solid front for any money
laundering operations done by the gang
however the main volume for their money
comes from the prostitution and human
trafficking
with a significant number of corporate
connections particularly arasaka
many high executives can be seen
regularly entering tiger claws
establishments and clubs
often carrying out side hustles for
arasaka where they're paid with high-end
cyber technology and military-grade
weapons
elizabeth lizzie borden a former
prostitute who owned a strip club in
night city
was identified for valuing her workers
and shielding them from violent patrons
unfortunately in 2067 one of her girls
was brutally raped and murdered by tiger
claws gang members
in an act of vengeance for their
atrocities lizzie took matters into her
own hands
and wielding an axe killed three of the
men responsible
she then displayed their bodies in the
front of her club as a message
this proclamation was a notice to all
regardless of who you are
and who you represent if you hurt one of
my girls
you will meet the same end but if there
is one gang you don't mess with
and one gang you don't threaten it's the
tigers
and lizzie most likely knew this and was
prepared to make the ultimate sacrifice
in order to be a martyr and protector of
her people
and so not long after act of defiance
the tiger claws raided
and demolished her bar killing her in
the process
and this was the event that triggered a
response that the tiger claws would not
have seen coming
the mox originates from the old slang
term moxie
which means the determination to stand
up against the oppressors
and that's just what the gang is they're
courageous in spirit
determined and persevere in their cause
lizzi's death set up a wave of riots all
over night city
and the tiger claws and their businesses
became the targets of unprecedented
violence
lizzie had become a symbol of defiance
against gang lawlessness
and brutality her bowel was rebuilt
and renamed lizzie's bar and the mox was
formed with the goal of protecting those
who felt threatened
and oppressed especially among sex
workers and sexual minorities
the mocks are a relatively small
non-territorial gang who are based in
lizzie's bar
and really venture outside of their
district consisting mostly of sexual
minorities
anarchists punks and sex workers the
group lacks a strict hierarchy
its members often refer to themselves as
those who protect working guys and girls
from violence and abuse however they do
demand a substantial fee for their
services
and it's important to remember that
these people are still a gang fighting
for control of their turf
the mocks prefer to wear clothing that
is a mix of punk and fashionable
low-priced garments
typically worn by prostitutes however
it's very seldom that they'll wear
clothes that restrict their movement
which means they still look more like
gang members than the typical sex worker
the majority of their income is
generated through lizzie's bar which is
now an exclusive braindance club
the latest deeply immersive virtual
reality form of the entertainment
they don't generally control a specific
area of night city
instead focusing on protecting their
facilities members and sex
workers who operate in the close
vicinity of lizzie's bar
as long as they are left to their
business they don't actively seek
conflict with other gangs
however to this day they still have a
rather tense interaction with the tiger
clause
these are just some of the gangs that
are present in night city and cyberpunk
2077
there will be a part two to this video
where i'll delve into the remainder of
them
depending on when you see this there
should be a thumbnail at the end of this
video that you can click on
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch you in the next
one cheers
[Music]
you